- I always enjoy sharing cool stories
from social media that
might make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat instrumental music)
So giving birth under the best
of circumstances is no joke.
It's no fun.
So imagine going into labor
and not being able to
get to any medical care.
It happened to a mama in rural Virginia
just after a monster
snowstorm came through.
The power lines were knocked down.
Trees blocked all the roads
and more than a foot of snow
had amassed on the ground,
but she didn't let any
of that stand in the way
of getting to the hospital,
trekking a quarter mile through the snow
to get to an ambulance.
(audience groans)
You know she wanted that baby out.
She was like, get out.
We have that brave mama
on the line right now
along with her husband and baby girl.
Let's say hi to Noel,
Chris and baby Josephine
watching on NBC Washington.
Hi.
Oh my gosh, you are adorable.
Look at baby Josephine.
Hi, hello.
(laughs)
Well congrats on baby Josephine.
So the snowstorm was worse
than you expected, right?
- It was way worse.
We knew it was supposed to snow
but it had been like 60
degrees the night before,
so we weren't expecting it to be that bad.
But when we woke up, there
was like a foot of snow
on the ground and it was still falling.
And then trees started coming down.
We lost power.
And Noel was over a week overdue
with our fourth child.
So I went out to see if we could even
get to the road from our dead end street.
And I saw like a barricade
of about 30 or 40 trees
all meshed together with power lines.
I tried to get through
and ended up stepping on a power line.
So I came back to the
house and I said to Noel,
you can't go into labor.
Don't move.
Just sit down because
we can't get out of here
and nobody is coming to us.
- So what did you do?
You're treking to the,
are you just like,
what is your emotional state
while you're trekking to an ambulance?
I mean, are you at the
point where you're kind
of anger or laughing hysterically?
'Cause you're like ha ha ha ha ha, like-
- Going in between the two.
- Oh my gosh.
- Oh my gosh, Kelly,
I was seriously panicking, like really.
So I wake up in labor and then,
you know, we tried to call my mom
and anyone else we could think of
that could possibly get to us
so we could go to the hospital.
No one could get out.
We called 911, silence.
We couldn't get through.
Luckily my mom was able to get ahold of
the fire and rescue up by her
who then called Stafford Fire and Rescue
and they were able to get to me.
But Kelly, they had to
walk a mile through snow
and fallen down trees to get to me.
And by the time they got here,
I had my boots on, I had my
bag packed, I was ready to go
and they sat me down and
they said, absolutely not.
We cannot leave.
But then I thought,
okay well there's a parallel street
that runs in our backyard,
like across the way.
If the ambulance can get there,
maybe we can walk to
the ambulance that way.
So we went ahead and tried.
My contractions were about two
minutes apart at this point.
So we had to stop every
time I had a contraction
but we walked through fallen down trees
and frozen creeks and chicken wire.
And we'd already decided
that we were gonna
name the baby after St. Joseph
and it really felt like, you know,
the Mary and Joseph, you
know, trek to Bethlehem.
(laughs)
And finally we get to the ambulance
and then baby Josephine was
born 7:00 AM the next morning.
- Oh my gosh.
Well I'm just telling you what,
baby Josephine, she's supposed
to do something powerful,
something wonderful with her life.
Thank you so much Noel and
Chris for sharing your story.
- [Noel] Thank you Kelly.
I'm liking your post right now.
(ding)
That's not all though.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen, makers of FriXion,
the to go erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like y'all.
I mean, you are fearless ma'am.
So they are giving you a
thousand dollars just to say
you're awesome.
- Oh whoa.
Thank you.
It's all going to coffee and diapers.
- Oh my God, right?
Yeah.
It is expensive.
Babies are expensive.
You are right.
Well God bless y'all.
Enjoy those four beautiful children.